now this is projection and speculation
but there is something different about
him in the past
several months it could be the covet
thing the isolation that you mentioned
i
listen to a lot of interviews and
speeches in russian
and there's uh
there's something about power over time
that can change you that can isolate you
well when i was there no he'd been in
office for
already 15 years
he had power
he didn't misuse it in my opinion he was
very even i saw him go on television and
talk to his fellows the same way he
always talked to them
he grew with it he grew in intelligence
and knowledge because he had he had
dealings with the whole world now people
had come to him he was very well known
in africa and middle east certainly
syria
and
i i just never saw a misuse
of his power i saw humility in him
actually
so perhaps
there was a calculation and he
calculated wrong
in terms of what happens if he doesn't
invade
perhaps there was a calculation perhaps
he had a calm and clear mind
and he calculated wrong well he also
made the point that he had there the
talk of zelinski saying
nuclear weapons were going to come into
ukraine there was talk about that right
before the invasion too and certainly
that would have set off alarms
you know the united states is already
kind of doing that
by not only putting its intelligence and
its heavy weaponry into ukraine
but you've got to deal with the question
the next question that comes up the most
immediate question is
is the united states going to start
and i'm saying this is good
they're making a lot of noise the united
states press about russia using nuclear
weapons and chemical weapons that's a
lot of noise
again going back to my analogy when the
united states starts that it starts the
conversation going it's in the interest
of the united states
for russia to be pinned with any kind of
chemical or nuclear
incident except for example it'd be very
not simple but it would be possible to
explode a nuclear device
in non-bass in donbass and kill
thousands of people
and we would not know right away who did
it but of course the blame would go
right to russia
right to russia even if it didn't make
sense if there was no motivation for it
it would just be blamed on russia the
united states might well be the one who
does that false flag operation it would
not be beyond them they would it would
be a very dramatic uh solution
to sealing this war off as a major
victory for the united states that's
terrifying no but it can happen it can
happen at one kiloton device low yield
this it's possible so when you walk
across that line you can potentially
never walk back
well i think the united states is
calculating that
it's a dangerous yes i agree but i think
the neoconservative arrogance is such
that they really believe they can push
their advantage to the max now
that because of all these propaganda
successes up to now
the ukrainian army could be wiped out
for all we know there's all this
leftists are neon nazi brigades but
they're being advised very well by the
us
and they're sending the weapons in our
huge amounts of weapons what about
american budget no one talks about how
much money we're giving to ukraine we
get it's a billion dollars already in
weaponry and not most of it just poured
in
what about uh
you know the the russian budget is uh
defense budget is 60 some billion
dollars a year it's nothing compared to
the united states 1 15th of it but yet
we we've put so much weaponry into
ukraine that the money we've spent
on ukraine is all equivalent almost to
what we've spent on on
coven in our own country it's astounding
the distortion of our priorities
uh there's also chemical don't forget
chemical is probably the easier way to
go but in syria there was far too many
incidents of of america in its quest to
demonize uh assad and the the russians
of all these chemical attacks that were
happening that
they were vowing came from russia and uh
in spite of the fact that russia just
pulled out of the uh signed the
agreement on chemical arms and not and
apparently destroyed its stock several
years ago
it's it's strange that the the strangest
incidents happened in syria you go back
to him trace everyone
good journalism was done the white
helmets got a lot of fame but they were
corrupted and many good journalists
tried to point out the inconsistencies
in the american uh uh accusations
robert perry among them uh who was one
of my mentors at consortium press a lot
of good journey you'd have to go back
but trace each like you would trace each
time you they made an accusation against
putin of murder
you need that same kind of sherlock
holmes intensity investigation and they
don't do it because the united nations
or the chemical
not the united nations as much as the
chemical people the uh the organization
has been tampered with if you remember
correctly there was accusations that the
chemical chemical uh
investigative unit i don't know the name
of
was tampered with
and people quit people who were working
on that commission quit and said that
this is not legit
it's a very interesting that syria story
is wacko
so the united states is willing to use
chemical in syria freely it did it three
four times if you remember correctly
trump was challenged that he did not
attack after a chemical incident in
syria uh
all these newscasters in the united
states uh the most heaviest of them were
saying well president putin is uh
president trump is now finally acting
like a real president when he attacks
when he drops missiles in syria they
actually said that in other words they
wanted the trump to go to war on syria
but he didn't
you